alexis poulain bonjour merci de répondre
à nos questions alors que la chancelière
angela merkel s'est excusé d'avoir voulu
renforcer les restrictions sanitaires
pour pâques
pas de mea culpa donc hier soir
d'emmanuel macron qui ont au contraire à
rejeter la faute 1 sur l'union
européenne mercredi soir qu'est ce que
ça traduit selon vous cette posture
ça traduit ce qu'on vit depuis quatre
ans emmanuel macron ne se trompe jamais
emmanuel macron est l'hôte de ces bois
le phénix le phare incroyable de la
pensée contemporaine il l
épidémiologiste en chef il n'a pas
écouté les médecins qui demandait un
confinement
alors que le vario anglais était en
train de se répandre sur le territoire
évidemment que le la coupe napa lui en
février les médecins à l'époque disait
attention les mois difficiles seront
mars et avril
nous y sommes finalement la voie étroite
un choisi par emmanuel macron le premier
de cordée et bien elle a déclenché une
avalanche une avalanche de qu'ovide
aujourd'hui nous sommes tous enseveli
sous cette épidémie il faut voir que
l'allemagne déclenché des mesures alors
que ces taux sont à 100% alors les
mesures nous on est bien au-delà sur le
taux d'incidence et l'allemagne
d'ailleurs ferme ses frontières avec la
france qui est considéré par la grande
bretagne la france et les autres
partenaires européens comme la zone
rouge a absolument éviter donc oui la
gestion calamiteuse des malades macron à
nous a rendus dans ce mur de co vide
aujourd'hui les soignants sont en
burn-out ils n'en peuvent plus les
hôpitaux bien sûr sont au delà de ce
qu'ils peuvent faire
malgré la promesse un taulier vers en
rappelez vous cet été d'ouvrir 12 milice
il le fallait et bien ils sont où ces
lits de réanimation qu'on devrait ouvrir
rapidement ils sont nulle part qu'est ce
qu'on fait on propose aux familles de
trimballer les malades
il ya des transports sanitaires qui sont
vides pour la plupart puisque les
familles refusent évidemment de voir
leurs proches s'éloigner alors qu'elles
sont malades
donc on est dans un dans une gestion
ubuesque une gestion criminels également
puisque bientôt emmanuel macron sera ce
monsieur cent mille morts on est à 93
mille morts cette semaine mais on voit
bien que à plus de 300 morts par jour du
coc vide ça va aller très vite
malheureusement pour nos concitoyens et
tout ça sans jamais se remettre lui en
cause et aucun remords aucun mea culpa
aucun constat d'échec
alors que faut-il faire pour qui l'ol
mâcon se réveille se rendre compte que
il ne doit pas faire les choix seul et
il doit écouter maintenant des
responsables
médicaux et scientifiques et puis il
doit aussi aller chercher ailleurs y
avoir il va y avoir des mesures qui vont
être prises prochainement il l'a pas
exclure d'ailleurs emmanuel macron hier
soir on sait qui à l'aube le rhône et la
nièvre qui sont confinement light est
dès ce soir malgré les 45 mille nouveaux
cas de couronnes au virus enregistrés
ces dernières 24 heures qu'est ce qui va
se passer donc du coup ces prochaines
semaines vous qui savez lire entre les
lignes c'est quoi c'est préparer
l'opinion publique à un confinement
strict avec fermeture des écoles par
exemple on peut rappeler également ce
sondage est là dans cette semaine 58%
des personnes interrogées estiment que
le gouvernement a eu tort de ne pas re
confiné en janvier 73% pensent que les
mesures annoncées jeudi dernier ne sont
pas efficaces
oui alors il ya évidemment comme neil
mac on ne peut pas se contredire et
qu'il a dit on ne confondra pas on va
confiné sans le dire donc cesser
confinement régionaux qui vont s'étendre
sur toute la carte sans doute alors je
suis pas devin mais clairement je suis
pas non plus médecin mais le variés
anglais visiblement il se trimballe très
rapidement par tous y compris chez les
jeunes est alors quand vous entendez le
ministre de la santé dire oui
effectivement le verrier anglais touche
les plus jeunes et il y à des
contaminations à l'école donc nous le
regardons les écoles ouvertes c'est
super important
et puis vous allez le ministre de
l'éducation qui dit il faut que les
parents acceptent de tomber de malades
pour leurs enfants c'est important un
que l'école reste ouverte ou non mais on
est quand même nom mais c'est dingue
qu'on accepte d'être gouvernés par ce
genre de personnage mois m'inquiète et
que finalement 30% des français voire
plus trouve sa normal alors qu'on est
dans une folie sanitaire sécuritaire qui
est inefficace puisque confinement
couvre-feu amende si on est plus de 6,2
or dans les départements concernés etc
ça ne sert à rien ça ne sert à rien ce
qu'il faut c'est pourquoi les prises de
parole cette semaine on vient de le voir
à côté de vous sur sur les images
emmanuel m'apprend à valenciennes mardi
jeudi ce mercredi sur les s'exprimer
devant la télévision publique grecque
hier soir c'est donc une allocution
après le le conseil
européen pourquoi autant de sorties
médiatiques cette semaine parce qu'il
venait le maquereau est en campagne ou
n'êtes pas sans savoir qu'en 2022 c'est
l'élection présidentielle en france et
que déjà les candidats sortent leur leur
candidature et bien lui être candidat à
sa réélection il sait que s'il ne gère
pas correctement cette crise ce qu'il
est en train de faire c'est un échec pas
tenter alors il peut dire bye-bye 2022
donc il va en rajouter faire des tonnes
de communication engueuler tout le monde
autour de lui vous avez tous est un
discret dont la presse qu'ils disent à
la colère du président alors là c'est le
le signe d'un mauvais manager qui passe
son temps à houspiller ses troupes en
disant qu ils font n'importe quoi alors
que c'est lui qui décide in fine et avec
ce conseil de défense où tout reste sous
le sceau du secret défense
donc il est là en train de s'agiter
parce qu'ils vont dire qu'il perd la
bataille de l'image que les français
vont commencer pour ce qui lui faisait
encore confiance et bien à se tourner
vers d'autres parce que cette gestion de
crise sera fatal pour emmanuel macron
comme elle a été fatale pour plus de
90000 français actuellement cette
gestion crise avec les vaccinations faut
en parler également un 10 millions de
vaccinations pour la mi avril les
français qui le souhaitent vacciner
d'ici la fin de l'été donc c'est
l'objectif de l'exécutif
est-ce que c'est tenable selon vous
malgré les retards de livraison
notamment astrazeneca avec l'europe et
emmanuel macron tapé du poing sur la
table cette semaine
oui alors j'espère que c'est tenable
pour lui mais j'espère que les vaccins
vont être efficace contre les nouveaux
variants puisque nous parlons maintenant
du coronavirus comme de la grippe qui
reviendrait tous les ans avec de
nouveaux variants et c'est donc là on
est dans un temps long avec le problème
des labos qui vont me faire beaucoup de
profits 15 milliards d'euros rien que
pour pfizer sur sur son nouveau vaccin
astrazeneca qui ne livre pas assez
l'europe qui envoient plus de doses
qu'elle n'en distribue et donc tout ce
jeu un du libre échange du prix du
vaccin fait que nous manquons de vaccin
parce que nous n'avons nous n'avons pas
finalement payé le prix ou passer les
commandes avant les autres ça c'est
l'échec de la commission européenne mais
il ne faut pas dire que la commission
européenne a fait un mauvais boulot il
faut dire que c'est formidable parce que
comme ça tous les pays sont dans la même
pénurie y compris l'allemagne qui
commence à en avoir marre vous avez vu
angela merkel qui elle est prête à aller
commander elle même les vaccins russe
pour nick v s'il le faut ce qui n'est
pas le cas bien sûr des marelles mâcon
qui reste dans une gestion politique
idéologique de cette crise est donc là
on est avec cette annonce 10 millions de
français en avril puis 20 puis 30
millions puis tous les adultes qui
souhaitent être vaccinés à la fin de
l'été j'espère que cette annonce est une
annonce qui peut être tenues j'espère
que ces vaccins sont des vaccins qui
peuvent être efficaces sur le temps long
sinon je ne vois pas comment et dans le
maghreb peut s'en sortir c'est une des
pas question que lui d'ailleurs il est
question du pays aussi de la relance de
l'économie aujourd'hui on voit bien que
c'était les discussions également du
conseil européen l'europe n'a pas mis
assez de milliards de monnaie de singe
sur la table il va falloir faire encore
plus d'argent de dettes qu'ovide avec la
bce compte tenu de ce café joe biden aux
états unis avec encore plus de planche à
billets donc on est donc justement je me
permets de vous couper tout ce que j'ai
envie de vous poser cette essence sur le
quoi qu'il en coûte 1 d'emmanuel
m'apprendre du gouvernement on apprend
ce matin que le déficit public se creuse
à 9 2% du pib en 2020 la dette s'envole
à 115 2 7%
selon l insee puis les mesures de
soutien devrait coûter 32 milliards
d'euros en 2021 selon olivier dussopt le
ministre chargé des comptes publics donc
quid du quoi qu'il en coûte
ce quoi qu'il en coûte c'est quoi qu'il
va nous en coûter nous contribuables de
travailleurs citoyens de ce pays est
malade macron lui s'en lave les mains il
pourra partir dans la finance faire des
conférences dans le monde entier une
fois le pays ravagé c'est pas un
problème pour les élites
le problème c'est ce qui reste ce qu'ils
ne peuvent pas changer de pays ceux qui
doivent travailler qui vont se retrouver
au chômage
ceux qui ont perdu leur entreprise ceux
qui ont perdu la vie ce qui se suicident
parce qu'il n'ya pas de tunnel de sortie
aujourd'hui on est dans un ravage total
je parlais d'avalanche qu'ovide mais on
va avoir des avalanches bien sûr de
faillite malheureuse et tout ça avec ces
milliards qui vont bénéficier d'abord
aux banques éviter la faillite
systémique des banques à la finance pour
relancer une économie zombie alors que
peut-être que investir quelques
milliards seulement dans l'hôpital pour
qu'il fonctionne
quelques milliards dans la recherche
pour que nous soyons les premiers avec
un vaccin efficace en france ou en
europe ce qui n'a pas été le cas
tout ça aurait coûté bien moins cher que
cet argent qui va finalement et d'y
remettre l'économie européenne à genoux
pour qu'elles puissent être achetées à
bas prix par les chinois les américains
ou qui voudra bien racheté quelques
quelques entreprises encore debout on le
voit bien d'ailleurs la finance va très
bien puisque les entreprises qui vont
survivre à cette crise sanitaire
elles vont plutôt être courtisé par les
investisseurs
et puis le cac 40 qui a maintenu son
niveau d'activité même s'il a un peu
baissé malgré la baisse de pib de 8,5
points donc on est dans un délire où
l'économie réelle n'existe plus où il ya
beaucoup d'argent magique qui n'est pas
là pour renforcer les services de soins
qui n'est pas là pour aider les
soignants qui n'est pas là pour remettre
l'école sur pied ou quoi que ce soit
mais qui va être là pour sauver la bulle
financière qui est en train de
surchauffe et c'est du jamais vu je
crois que sans être demain on est
aux prémices d'une grave crise
économique bien pire que 1929 compte
tenu de cette inflation qui ne dit pas
son nom et qui est ce plan de relance
européen américain ou ce que vous voulez
mais qui fait que l'argent n'a plus
aucune valeur en réalité merci avec ses
poulains d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes éditorialistes